هذا د.  أنتوني فوسي ، مدير
المعهد الوطني للحساسية
والأمراض المعدية ، موضحًا بشكل صريح
حالة لقاح أو علاج
لفيروس كورونا ، حيث يواصل الرئيس ترامب
المبالغة في تفاؤل
الخلية ولكنك تريد أن تصفها
بإمكانية انضمام المخدرات المتاحة
لعلاج فيروس كورونا.  لي الآن محلل سي إن إن
الطبي د.  سيلين باوندر ،
أستاذ مساعد إكلينيكي
للطب والأمراض المعدية وطبيب ويو
بيلفيو ، وهو
دواء مضاد للملاريا يقول الرئيس ترامب إنه سيتم
توفيره على الفور تقريبًا ، لقد
كان بعيدًا عن هذا الحد ، ولا يزال
بحاجة إلى موافقة إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية.
يستغرقون شهورًا يحتاجون إليها لإجراء
تجارب سريرية يحتاجون إليها للتأكد من
عدم وجود أي آثار جانبية ،
هل لديك أي مخاوف بشأن هذا
الدواء بعينه ، ما مدى التفاؤل الذي يجب
أن تكون عليه الأمة كلارك عندما يكون من المعروف
أن لديها بعض الآثار الجانبية الخطيرة ،
وهناك أخرى  الدراسة التي خرجت من
فرنسا مؤخرًا تبحث في
هيدروكسي كلوروكين وهو دواء مرتبط
بمضاد حيوي شائع واعد جدًا ،
لكن كان حوالي 20 مريضًا فقط
بحيث لا يمنحك حقًا
معلومات كافية عن السلامة أو
الفعالية.  أعتقد أن ما
سنراه يحدث هو أشخاص مثلي
هم أطباء يعملون في المستشفى
سنقوم بوصف بعض منهم  هذه الأدوية
عندما تكون متاحة وربما تحاول
قدر الإمكان
تسجيل المرضى في هذه التجارب السريرية
لمعرفة ما إذا كانت هذه الأشياء تعمل ولكن هناك
هذا ليس من قبيل البطولات الاربع ، فهذا
بحث واعد مبكرًا ولكن هذا لا يعني أن
هذا  ذاهب إلى العمل خلال
دار البلدية مساء أمس د.  قال فوسي إن
المعاهد الوطنية للصحة
تطلق تجربة علاج فيروس كورونا
باستخدام الأجسام المضادة من المرضى
الذين تعافوا مما
يمكننا تعلمه من المرضى المتعافين جيدًا
لقد فعلنا ذلك مع أمراض أخرى
أيضًا أثناء الإيبولا ، كان هناك دواء
يسمى  لقد تبين أن zmapp الذي جربناه
لم يكن فعالًا بشكل كبير ، فقد
استخدمنا هذا مع عدوى أخرى مثل
جدري الماء أو التهاب الكبد B ولذا
هناك دور لهذا ولكنك تعلم أنك ما
زلت تنتظر بعد ذلك إصابة شخص ما
بالمرض وعندما تحاول ذلك  إنقذهم
بعقار مثل هذا ليس هناك ما
يضمن أنه سيعمل إذا
تعافى شخص ما من
الفيروس ، فهل يمكنه إعادة العدوى
أم أنه مثل جدري الماء يمكنك
الحصول عليه مرة واحدة فقط حيث كان هناك الكثير من
الالتباس حول ما نعتقد أنه  بناءً
على ما نعرفه عن جميع
فيروسات كورونا الأخرى ، إذا كنت مصابًا
بـ kovat 19 ، فستكون محصنًا ضد
Kovan 19 بعد ذلك على الأقل لمدة سنة إلى
ثلاث سنوات ، لذلك  على الأقل خلال هذه الموجة ،
يجب ألا تكون قادرًا على إعادة العدوى
الآن لأن الانتكاس المذكور هو احتمال ،
بمعنى آخر أنك مصاب بالعدوى
تبدأ في التحسن ثم
تسوء مرة أخرى لذا قد يكون هذا بعضًا مما
نراه و  ثم مع تطور الفيروس
بمرور الوقت ، قائلاً إن ثلاث سنوات من
الوقت تعلم أنه قد يتغير بما يكفي لأن
مناعتك ليست قوية كما كان في
البداية مثل هذا الوقت الصعب بالنسبة
للكثيرين منا في الخطوة الأولى هي
التفكير في الشعور بإمكانية التنبؤ
إحساسنا بالروتين ، نعلم أن ذلك يقلل من
الاستجابة للضغط ، وبالتالي فإن العثور على
خطط صغيرة على مدار اليوم يمكن أن
تظل متسقة من يوم إلى آخر
يمكن أن يكون مفيدًا حقًا في
مشاهدة نومك وهو أمر مهم للغاية ، فهو معرض
للتهديد الآن لأننا
قلقون للغاية ولكن بعد ذلك يكون الأمر بمثابة ضربة مزدوجة
عندما لا نحصل على نوم جيد ، فنحن أكثر
حساسية للتهديد ، لذلك نحن نعلم
أننا نشعر بالهواء النقي بشكل أسوأ عندما يكون من
الآمن القيام بذلك ، حتى الأجزاء الصغيرة من
ضوء الشمس يمكن أن تكون مفيدة للغاية
بالطبع ، جزء كبير هو أنك تعرف إبقاء
عقلك نشطًا دون الذهاب إلى
وضع الكارثة ، لذا فإن وضع
حدود عندما تبدأ في مراقبة
أفكارك ، فأنت تعرف جيدًا ، هل أجد
معلومات هنا تساعدني على الشعور بمزيد
من التحكم هل تكتسب البصيرة أم
أنا  نوع من الالتفاف حول هذا
والبدء في الدوران إلى مكان مظلم حقًا
وأحتاج إلى الرجوع خطوة إلى الوراء
وأحتاج إلى إعادة التعيين والحصول على تغيير بسيط
في المشهد حتى داخل منزلي ،
بالطبع أكبر شيء على الإطلاق
الآن أيضًا  من المحتمل أن نتأكد من
أن التباعد الاجتماعي لا يتحول إلى
عزلة اجتماعية كاملة لأننا نعلم
أن له آثارًا خطيرة للغاية على الصحة العقلية
خاصة بالنسبة للأشخاص الذين يشعرون
بشكل خاص بالعزلة عن أحبائهم في
الوقت الحالي ، فكيف يتعامل الناس مع
ذلك إذا كانوا "  تشعر بالعزلة
والوحدة لأنهم لكي نكون صادقين ، فهم
معزولون ووحيدون ، ما الذي يجب عليهم
فعله للمساعدة في
التخفيف من ذلك ، نعم تعلم أنه كان من
الصعب رؤية الناس حقاً  لكي تصبح
مبدعًا ، فأنت تعلم أن لديك
ساعات سعيدة افتراضية في الطهي مع بعضنا البعض عبر
FaceTime مثل دعنا نطبخ العشاء معًا ،
فأنت تعلم مشاهدة الأفلام معًا قائلين:
هيا نتناول الإفطار معًا
نعزف على آلاتنا لبعضنا البعض
أو نقرأ نفس الكتاب معًا
ونتحدث عنه على الهاتف  ومن المفارقات
، أعتقد أن أحد النقاط الإيجابية التي تعرفها
في هذا الرعب الأكبر هو أنه يتعين على
الناس إيجاد طرق
للالتقاء ، ولأن الكثير من الناس
محاصرون في المنزل ، فإن ذلك يمنحهم تقريبًا
المزيد من الحافز ليقولوا إنني حقًا بحاجة إلى
شيء هنا وأنا.  سأحقق
ذلك بالطبع ، لا يمكننا جميعًا فعل
ذلك ، فهذا يعتمد على تقنيتنا ، ولكن في
الحقيقة حتى أنت تعلم أن الوصول إلى أحد
الجيران عبر مكالمة هاتفية قديمة الطراز
يمكن أن يكون مفيدًا حقًا في الوقت الحالي ، وأعتقد أيضًا
أنه من المهم أن يقوم الأشخاص  فقط
اعترف أن
هذا أمر مروع حقًا ، لا
بأس تمامًا أن تكون منزعجًا وعاطفيًا
وفزعًا في المنزل ، أعني أننا
سنواجه صعوبة  هذا ما
سيفعله العالم في الولايات المتحدة
ولكنه صعب ولا يتعين
علينا التظاهر بأن الأمر ليس كذلك ، نعم
، هذه نقطة جيدة أعتقد
أن قبول بعض القلق الآن أمر
طبيعي جدًا ، ظروفنا ليست
طبيعية
ولكن  يمكن أن يكون رد فعلنا القلق حيال ذلك أمرًا
طبيعيًا جدًا ، هل يمكننا تسخير ما يمكننا
إدارته بحيث يمكننا مراقبة أنفسنا
ومحاولة العثور على جيوب من اليوم حيث
نجلس ونتنفس ونقول إن هذا
صعب حقًا هل هناك جزء من هذا
أنت  أعلم أنني سأتذكر بطريقة
تساعدني على النمو وأعلم أن هذا يبدو
سخيفًا نوعًا ما عندما نكون قلقين للغاية ولكن
التفكير في كيف يمكننا أن ننظر إلى
الوراء ونكون الأشخاص الذين نريد أن
نكون في هذه اللحظات يمكن أن يكون
قويًا حقًا  بين القلق
ومحلات البقالة التي اشتريناها لتستمر حتى
عام 2025 ، كلنا الذين قررنا
الحجر الصحي الذاتي نواجه الآن عميد كوفا
بعض الجنيهات الإضافية من الجلوس
محاطًا بالإجهاد والوجبات الخفيفة ، لذا
إليك بعض النصائح المفيدة للموظفين  بصحة جيدة
أثناء البقاء في المنزل ، تناول هذا الهدوء يقول:
ضع خطة للوجبات تلتزم بها بدون أي عذر
لعدم وجود وقت للتخطيط مسبقًا ، كل ما
لدينا هو الوقت التالي ، وضع جدولًا لأن
الخطر الحقيقي يكمن في الرعي طوال اليوم ،
لذا
تتبع وجباتك باستخدام التطبيقات  مثل
MyFitnessPal سوف يتجنب BLT أو
اللعقات والأذواق التي يمكن أن تكتسب
أرطالًا وتناول الطعام فقط في المطبخ أو
غرفة الطعام حتى لا يصبح منزلك بأكمله
عبارة عن بوفيه وأخيراً يظل
تخمينًا نشطًا حيث لا يمكنك التقاط كوف في 19
تذهب الغابة في نزهة طويلة تجعل الأطفال يقومون
بسباقات في الفناء الأمامي أو
يتفقدون التدريبات الرائعة في المنزل ، تحقق من
صالات الألعاب الرياضية المحلية التي يقدمها الكثيرون دروسًا
في البث المباشر بدلاً من
عضويتك وإذا كان هناك شيء واحد
يربطنا في التباعد الاجتماعي
فهو  العالم في المنزل بما في ذلك
الرياضيين من الطراز العالمي مثل لاعبة الجمباز الصينية Cheng il
الذين سيرشدونك خلال التدريبات التي
يمكنك القيام بها من غرفة المعيشة الخاصة بك ، لذا ابق في
المنزل حافظ على نشاطك ، ولكن الأهم من ذلك ،
دعنا نبقى سويًا للبقاء عاقلين